[موسيقى]
استنفار امنيا عسكري في جزيره باري
الاندونيسيه حيث تعقد قمه العشرين في ظل
تحديات تواجه العالم تاثرا بالحرب الدائره
في اوكرانيا عوامل جعلت قيمه بالي من اكثر
قمم المجموعه توتر منذ تاسيسها عام 99 اذ
اقترننت اجنده مجموعه العشرين خلال عقدين
الماضيين بالقضايا الاقتصاديه والازمات
الماليه
اندونيسيا ساعات الى انجاح القمه وضمان
مشاركه جميع الدول وان لا يؤدي لاستقطاب
الذي افرزته حرب اوكرانيا الى تغيب اي من
الدول الاعضاء مثلا
الاهتمام بكل تفاصيل الاستعدادات وقد جاهز
الجيش والشرطه عناصرهم لتوفير الحمايه
ونرجو ان تسير الامور بنجاح الترتيبات
اكتملت والاجتماعات الثنائيه كثيره
والجدول مزدحم انعقاد القمه في اندونيسيا
لها علاقات مست مره مع جميع اطراف الحرب
في اوكرانيا طرح منذ وقت مبكر تساؤلات حول
ما يمكن ان تقدمه في مسار تهدئه الحرب او
في قضايا الصحه والغذاء والطاقه والتحول
الرقميه التي ساعد جاكرتا الى التركيز
عليها خلال شهور من الاجتماعات التحضيريه
والوزريه
ولا تعد مجموعه العشرين تكتل الاقليميا
بالمنتدن يجمع بين الدول السبع الكباري
وثلاثه عشر دوله ناميه وصاعده اقتصاديه
ومواقفها تقترب من الالتزام او التعهد
السياسي اكثر من كونها ملزمه قانونيه
ولهذا تختلف وتتفاوت القضايا التي تشغل
دولها لها ويبر ذلك التباين حتى في
الملفات غير السياسيه في ظل الاستقطاب
الحادث بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا والتوتر في
بحر جنوب الصين
فيما ساعه اندونيسيا الى احراز تقدم في
المحاور التي تسهم في تحقيق الاستقرار
السياسي والتنميه المستدامه رغم تباينه
اولوياته الدول الاعضاء
بين فريقين ولكل مصالح مختلفه فالدول
المتقدمه تتحدث عن تطلعات الاقتصاديه
المتقدمه
تجاوزته اهتمامات ناميه المعنيه
بالاستثمار والتنميه والتعامل مع الهوه
التقنيه والرقميه وفي ارياف جزيره بالي
وبعيدا عن اروقه القمه واجتماعاتها ينشغل
المواطنون بنفسه هموم حياه غيرهم حول
العالم ابتداء بما يرتبط بازمه الغذاء وهي
واحده من بضع قضايا رئيسيه مطروحه في قمه
العشرين الى جانب العمل على تعزيز منظومه
صحيه عالميه تواجه الاوبئه والتحول
المستدامه الى الطاقه النظيفه والتحول
الرقمي سهيل جاسم الجزيره الجزيره تبالي